the metaphor the model told in your mind
as you gaze that at the earth in its
travail is the metaphor of birth not
death that a gestation process of 20,000
years is coming to an end culture using
language using minded creatures are
coming to some kind of fermentative
climax and we cannot extrapolate the
human career on this planet centuries
into the future it ain't going to be
like that it's an absurd question to ask
the question what will be what will the
world be like and 500 years what the
world will be like in 500 years is
unimaginable because in the next 40
years we are going to pass through this
quantized transition where we actually
become insiders and players in the game
history is a state of becoming it's a
state of moving from the inarticulate
unreflecting animal style of
organization to the self reflecting
minded conscious energy controlling
style but to get from one to the other
takes about 20,000 views and it's a
[ __ ] you don't know where you want you
don't know up from down you cannot tell
what is happening there's just
migrations and warfare and pogroms or
gene mixing and hysteria of every sort
and messiah this and religion that and
they're slaughtering these people
and these people are doing it and it's
like a bad dream it's like a psychedelic
trip it's what it's like it's a 15 to 25
thousand year dash to authentic being
from the animal body and it would have
been a lot easier to understand if ten
thousand years ago we hadn't cut the
telephone wire to nature